Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie.
This is going to be my Star Wars Obi-Wan Kenobi
video everyone's asking where the hell is
he he's in there and they have a plan for
him.
So I'm going to explain what that is there
is a new round of the Star Wars giveaway it's
for two IMAX gift certificates.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video be sure
to click that bell to enable alerts so you
don't miss anything during the break.
So everybody has seen the plans for the next
couple of Star Wars movies.
We know about the Skywalker saga films and
then we know about the next anthology film
after Rogue one the Han Solo film, but no
mention of and Obi wan film there were announced
plans for a really down and dirty gritty Boba
Fett movie that Josh Trank was going to make
there was a teaser.
They were going to release Fort that they'd
already worked on.
It was happening around the time they were
revealing Rogue one at celebration last year,
but because of the mess was fantastic four
Josh Trank's career went on the toilet they
just put Boba Fett on the shelf, but the thing
here is that there's no Obi-Wan of their everybody
is wondering where's the Obi wan spinoff film
next to Luke Skywalker next to Han.
So the like why would you do want.
You know there's talk of a Yoda film, but
Obi wan seems like it be an easier slamdunk
but supposedly there's a really important
reason for that the saga films themselves
like the really big saga films have a plan
for Obi-Wan Kenobi that will play out won't
be completely revealed till episode eight
in episode nine fully till episode nine.
So the theory is that the Obi-Wan character
is very important to some of the bigger reveals
of the new films in that if they were to do
a spinoff film for him explaining what he
did during that time between films it would
begin to spoil some of the big twists and
turns of the saga films, so think about that.
What's one of the biggest reveals of the saga
films we haven't seen yet Rey and her origin.
A lot of people even Daisy Ridley the actors
herself feels like episode seven kind of explain
who her parents were without going as far
say like holding up a family photo saying
you know mom dad daughter so you have Rey
touching the lightsaber it showing her all
those visions of the past actually brought
Ewan McGregor into the studio to record new
dialogue for that scene, he just screams that
you know and you can know on the most basic
level, it's a scene the just meant to show
her the history of the lightsaber itself what
happened to its wielder Anakin Skywalker,
but is also intended is kind of a warning.
This could happen to you to as well if you're
not careful the force of very complicated.
It just depends on the choices that you make.
So later when people went to McGregor and
started talking to him about coming back to
the new Star Wars films.
He said he was very open to it and if you
look at him.
He's actually taken very good care of himself
he slowly aging him into a very age-appropriate
Obi-Wan Kenobi think about how old Alec Guinness
was an episode for Ewan McGregor is and can
it be that old for a long time.
So, were they to do in Obi-Wan Kenobi spinoff
films set between episode three and episode
four.
He would be like a slightly younger version
than the Alec Guinness Obi-Wan Kenobi you
can see how he be an older more mature version
then he was in episode three, which is the
idea that there holding off on Obi-Wan in
the current films right now the spinoff films
because he's going to be much more important
later Star Wars has big plans for Obi-Wan
Kenobi much bigger than they let on.
Just think about how much secrecy is surrounding
episodes eight in episode nine right now cannot
even finish off the teaser supposedly until
next spring.
Maybe not even till March at the earliest.
So, I know a lot of people were wondering
if Rey might be related to Obi-Wan Kenobi.
I think the films have effectively told us
she's not a Skywalker with the new saga films
are effectively a Skywalker saga.
So she would have to be someone relatively
important to the Skywalker family.
So the next step on that letter would be to
make her a Kenobi it would either mean that
she's related to someone else in Obi-Wan Kenobi's
family so she stares blood with them.
She could be related to Kenobi without actually
being the daughter or granddaughter of Obi-Wan
Kenobi, but he's literally one of her progenitors
there's only a couple people that we know
about that he actually had romances with in
only one of those people is still part of
the canon in the clone wars he actually had
something of a romance with Satine it was
only implied, but she be the most likely person
for Obi-Wan to have a child with and if you
never watch the clone wars all explained Satine's
character she's really interesting.
She was featured in about 13 episodes of the
clone wars, which is a whole lot all across
the middle and later seasons many many episodes
and she's been referenced a lot during Star
Wars rebels recently as well as things that
happen around her life and death during the
clone wars, which should have been so and
present-day she's dead she died at the hands
of Darth Maul during the clone wars, but there
was a long time between when Obi-Wan first
met her and when she died there were many,
many episodes that feature her.
So just plenty of room in there for those.
So.
Just explain a little bit more about Satine
she was royalty on her planet interesting
thing about Rey's name is that it is Spanish
for King.
Meaning that she has the sort of grand destiny
ahead of her like she's meant to be the beginning
of this grand new dynasty of the Jedi order.
They baloney exorcism funny stuff in this
actually makes you think a little bit more
about Rey being extra special kind of flowing
from her lineage is the Satine was modeled
after Cate Blanchett when she played Queen
Elizabeth and Elizabeth and Elizabeth the
Golden age of the basically modeling this
character after one of the most powerful queens
in English history Cate Blanchett obviously
very beautiful as well to but can you just
imagine Rey being the daughter of Cate Blanchett
inside the Star Wars universe the recent rebels
had to if you haven't been watching rebels
they totally gave her a shout out, but it
was more of a reference to the clone wars
in the stuff that Darth Maul did when he encountered
Obi-Wan and her during their adventures.
This is actually the dark saber underneath
her picture will will will him that that lightsaber
the that you only him from his hair she thinks.
So when Darth Maul says your man DeLorean
friend could explain this to you.
This is basically the dark saber which is
a huge thing in Star Wars canon that showed
up when Obi-Wan was that man the lower with
Satine who was man DeLorean royalty.
So you start to think about the idea of the
dark saber in your get really excited, but
the two that the idea that Rey might flow
from man DeLorean heritage, which makes you
think about the Boba Fett film that they have
sitting on the shelf right now to, so don't
get too sad about that don't worry Boba Fett
man DeLorean things will come back to the
Star Wars universe of eventually but for those
you that you been complaining that the main
films have not been referencing rebels or
the clone wars enough for the animated series.
The stuff that still canon because all that
stuff still is canon we could see the dark
saber pop back up in the main films but also
the idea that Rey flows from a dark pass just
like Luke Skywalker flowing from Anakin Skywalker
who became Darth Vader just to bring you back
around to actual physical Obi-Wan in the new
films really like the way to bring him back
is just like they brought him back in episode
seven as a voice as a force ghost like you
see Obi-Wan in the original trilogy because
even though they only really got into it during
the end of clone wars where Yoda learns how
to become a force ghost he is essentially
a mortal now and when Luke Skywalker eventually
dies the same thing will happen to him.
So even if they move on past the Skywalker
family in another trilogy after episode nine
because there is talk that they won't focus
on the Skywalker family after episode nine
which I'm totally fine with they can still
invoke Luke Skywalker in the Skywalker family
via force ghost, but there's been so much
talk about the may be doing it Obi-Wan trilogy
not just a single Obi-Wan film but a new Obi-Wan
trilogy after the new films.
I don't know if the go that far, but there
will be a lot of Obi-Wan in the Star Wars
universe still Iveco say without giving away
spoilers.
There are some Obi-Wan Easter egg some visual
Easter eggs as well as some verbal shoutout
reference Easter eggs in Rogue one.
So in that just look out for multiple different
types of Obi-Wan things happening.
So all explained that when I post my Easter
Egg video later this weekend what can happen
is I'll post new DC later tonight that I'll
post my Rogue one Easter egg video on Saturday.
So will say congratulations to this week's
giveaway winner Jeffrey Gibson you in the
IMAX gift certificates I did start a new round
of the beginning of this, so I'll announce
the winner when I post that Easter egg video.
So get hype Rogue one was a lot of fun I'll
post my non-spoil review at the end of this
and you know worry they will start dropping
some Star Wars episode eight stuff pretty
soon what you guys wait for that to post you
can click here for my non-spoilery Rogue one
review and you can click here to learn all
about the fastest speedsters on the flash
thank you so much watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight!